with any philosopher who we might be
choosing to study it's a natural
question what am I going to get out of
investing the time and the thought and
perhaps even aggravation of studying
their works and this is a perfectly
reasonable question in the case of David
Hume I think that there's some pretty
strong answers to this and we can start
with the superficial ones well we all
know that he's a really important
philosopher and you don't want to skip
over any of the really big names and
even down to the present if you do
polling of philosophers or you look at
histories of philosophy or introductory
philosophy textbooks and classes David
Hume gets mentioned a lot that's nice
right
that gestures towards something why is
David Hume considered to be so important
to be you know up there with say Renee
Descartes or Emmanuel Kant who's going
to follow shortly after him or Aristotle
or Plato or any of these other big names
well it has something to do with the
importance of his philosophy and his
works and the influence that he has
exercised both you know for and against
him people picking things up and also
criticizing things in him responding to
him in important ways in the you know
more than two centuries since he has
passed away after writing quite a bit
and some of his writings by the way were
published after he died we'll talk about
why that's the case so you know Hume is
incredibly influential we can say that
he's part of this important lineage or
tradition or sometimes called School of
empiricist so he's going to influence
other people who identify with let's
call it empiricism broadly speaking
uh he's also going to provoke a kind of
counter-reaction by somebody I've
already mentioned Emmanuel Kant who
takes Hume as providing
a challenge to causality itself that he
that Kant thinks we have to address
um winds up being very influential on
British philosophy in general
particularly on the 20th century
analytics who will not only be you know
taking him as a major figure but also
drawing upon him sometimes against as I
mentioned against him saying Hume is
wrong about this sometimes saying he's
actually right about things in terms of
moral philosophy and metaphysics and
philosophy of religion so AJ air is a
prime example of somebody who does talk
of about Kant but very much acknowledges
himself as being within the current of
him but you'll find influences by Hume
in all sorts of other interesting places
as well including Continental philosophy
not only are people like Jill de Luz in
the late 20th century writing about him
taking things from him but we see that
Edmund huseral when it comes to how
Association Works particularly in his
passive synthesis lectures is going to
be taking things almost directly from
David Hume Lev shastoff the great you
know anti-systematic existentialist
philosopher references Hume quite a bit
so you'll you'll you'll find him in a
surprisingly large number of places
being brought up I also think personally
that Hume is a great great thinker and a
great writer I disagree with him on many
things but he's worthwhile and also once
you get get past the language perhaps
quite fun to read I greatly enjoy going
back to his works it's one reason why I
make sure to teach him in class is it's
not just because he is influential not
just because he has interesting ideas
but also because he is fun to teach and
to get other people
interested in and his you know proposals
and ideas and engagements with other
philosophers I would say are interesting
in their own right
and then there's one other reason why I
would say it's particularly important to
study Hume and that is because he has
through his influence
um and because he's such a great
Wordsmith he has bequeathed us a number
of cultural reference points that are
basically like sound bites or the
equivalent thereof and it's good to know
what Hume actually did think about
things you know so for example probably
the most famous one reason is and can
only be the slave of the passions right
well that's not exactly what Hume thinks
he did say it but there's a lot more to
the relationship between
reasoning and our emotional life than
just that sound bite so you only find
that out when you actually study him or
at least study losses upon him these
so-called Humes Fork you know that
occurs at the end of the inquiry
concerning human understanding about uh
you know relations of ideas or matters
of fact if a book doesn't contain those
consign it to the Flames for it contains
nothing I'm paraphrasing but sophistry
an illusion
uh yes he says that does he really mean
that again by studying his work you can
see that he's much more of a judicious
writer than that would imply so those
are some good reasons for getting into
it now let's shift to a different topic
as always there are some practical
questions for the self-directed learner
that we we really do need to bring up
you might not have thought of these but
you will want to think through these and
these have to do with hume's Texas
writings and how you should proceed
through them how you can actually make
some Headway and the first thing I'm
going to bring up is what I like to call
the issue of non-translation now this is
something specific to English writing
texts in Philosophy from previous
centuries written for different kinds of
audiences than we typically are today
and here's the problem or the issue in a
nutshell so with authors like Plato
writing in Greek or Friedrich Nietzsche
writing in German or Renee Descartes
writing in LA Latin and French if we
want to take their work and put it into
contemporary 21st century ordinary
person English we can do that right and
so there's always newer translations
arising we can't really do that when it
comes to you know 17th 18th 19th even
20th century sometimes difficult English
language writers because what we would
be doing instead is sort of a
boulderization of their works and people
don't generally like that you're messing
around with a text right so you're stuck
with hume's 18th century English and
actually in some editions you'll also
get the weird kind of
punctuation and capitalization that
people were doing back then as well so
that can be a bit of a problem just
expect that to be the case you may have
to expand your vocabulary a bit in order
to fully understand what Hume is saying
and words don't always mean exactly what
they do in the present uh when we're
reading them in an older text so that's
one thing to be forewarned about
um
another thing that I think is helpful to
keep in mind as well
sort of again background knowledge is
Hume is a philosopher he's also a
historian he's a literary figure these
were not rigidly distinguished from each
other you know the way that we typically
do in universities today where we say
you go over there you go over there and
maybe we invite each other over once in
a while and we shelve things differently
on the bookshelves as well in bookstores
and libraries and perhaps even in our
own home collections so Hume is writing
in a context in which you know there's
all sorts of blending and back and forth
and the field of philosophy was rather
different you are not going to see Hume
referring to Aristotle as being an
important philosopher
um very often
in part because there wasn't as much
interest in Aristotle in the 18th
century he tended to be identified with
a more abund
scholasticism of the Middle Ages and
modern period that was viewed as kind of
a you know Backwater
instead you're going to see him talking
much more about other philosophical
traditions the platonist the skeptical
the stoic the Epicurean to talk about
four main essays that he writes about
philosophers he's going to be engaging
with a lot of the philosophers of the
previous centuries you know for example
Rene Descartes Nikolai malbras you know
Thomas Hobbs John Locke all of these
people as well
as and some people who you've probably
never really heard of as well and that's
that's quite all right he's in a
different milieu than we are I do want
to say that Hume is a big fan of Cicero
who he actually takes some models from
which we'll talk about in a bit and
you're going to see Hume is quite
erudite bringing up quotations passages
from all sorts of people so you know
just be ready for that a good additions
will typically have you know some
footnotes or or some some glosses on
that that'll help you understand what's
going on another thing that I think
might be helpful to keep in mind from
the very start
Hume is not a systematic philosopher in
the way that some other people that you
might have read is he's not totally
anti-systematic either he is developing
a set of you know connected
interconnected studies of things but
he's doing so over time and it doesn't
produce a complete and perfected system
he's also not just proceeding from a
bunch of axioms or principles and then
do sing things he thinks that it's
really quite important to look at the
world and figure things out along those
those lines and we'll we'll talk about
that in a bit now it's natural that
you're going to ask well great that's
that's all fine that's nice context
background information what should I
actually read and we're going to get to
the question of what to start with in
just a bit but I do want to say a few
things about in very very broad Strokes
about what is out there and available so
you notice I've got a lot of books piled
up
essays moral and political and literary
big collection here you can find this in
smaller volumes as well
this is a really helpful addition it's
been done over and over again originally
put together by Eugene Miller and
including a whole bunch of different
essays right so this is this is a text
in whatever form you're going to get it
that you probably want to get your hands
on another thing that you'll probably if
you want to do some serious study of
David Hume you probably want to want
you'll want to get A Treatise of human
nature and this is the you know typical
uh thing uh revised in notes by nittich
one big thick book okay this is one of
hume's very early and import important
works not that important in his lifetime
unfortunately he exaggerates a little
bit in saying it fell stillborn from the
Press but it certainly didn't as we say
set the world on fire as a matter of
fact his essays were much more widely
read during his lifetime and I think
that it can also be quite good to get
your hands I mean you can find these
separate from each other but you can
also find the two inquiries you know
regarding human understanding and and
you know moral principles of morals in
one uh handy volume again edited in this
case by nittich that's good to get and
one text that you're definitely not
going to want to skip at all
um if you're if you're interested in
reading and understanding him dialogues
concerning natural religion you can
again find this from a lot of different
places sometimes it's bundled together
with some of his other texts concerning
religion which we'll talk about in just
a minute but you know that's
um those are some of the volumes that
you're going to want to get your hands
on no no there is good news about this
you don't have to necessarily buy all of
this any good library has probably got
available at least one copy if not more
of each of these texts and probably
other tax buy and about David Hume and
you can find
practically all of them available online
as well because you know his works are
in the public domain so there's there's
a lot of good stuff there to help get
you started now let's talk about where
and how to start
so I gave a lot of thought to this
question about where do you actually
start with David Hume and there isn't
any
suggesting itself right off the bat is
the only correct answer starting point
as there is for a certain philosophers
who may have given this some some
thought and I'm actually going to
propose to you
something that may seem a little bit
strange that you don't begin immediately
with philosophical works as such
I would say that and again you're
perfectly free to ignore this suggestion
and go on to other works that maybe if
you haven't read any David Hume
maybe the place to begin is with this
essay that you can find bundled together
sometimes that he wrote Close to the end
of
my own life
where Hume is speaking in his own words
to you about you know his biography and
what he takes to be important in it and
it's short and you could easily read
your way through it in you know less
than than an hour perhaps less than 20
minutes for a lot of readers and then
there's one other thing that I think
could be quite helpful
to begin with and it's actually one of
his uh essays
and it's called
um there we go uh of essay writing right
where he is giving you his take on how
and why and in what Manner uh the
elegant part of mankind
um who are you know learned and
conversible
ought to write and also in some respects
ought to read and interpret and I think
this is very interesting he talks about
you know
um what is going on with men of letters
and this could extend to women of
letters too in his own age but I think
it also could apply to our own and so
this gives you a sense of what what
humans up to why he's writing the things
that he is now so those are kind of
idiosyncratic starting points and they
both will be very quickly resolved you
want to get into some serious philosophy
where do you want to go now I'm of
several different Minds about this
I think that there could be several
useful starting points
and I would actually suggest not
beginning where I think a lot of people
who would view themselves as more
serious Scholars than than myself might
suggest that you begin with the treaties
of human nature I mean it's good stuff
it is a
systematic work it is hume's first major
work right and you should definitely
read it at some time and I would say
fairly early on but I don't know I've
been teaching him and and you know
introducing people to him for many many
years and I would actually say that
maybe the text that I use in
introduction to philosophy not the
entire text but portions of the inquiry
concerning human understanding I would
actually say that might be the better
place to begin and there's a couple
reasons for that you're getting a lot of
his key ideas both from the treaties and
from some other works as well mixed in
there and worked out in a more polished
form Hume himself took the there were
three books to the treaties of human
nature the first book Is you know of the
understanding and that's what he's going
to transform into the inquiry concerning
the human understanding the second book
is of the passions and he will present
parts of that in other works that we'll
we'll talk about in a bit and then the
third part is of morals and so that is
going to become you know the inquiry
concerning um principles of of
uh morals right so I would say start
with the inquiry concerning human
understanding and then maybe go on to
the inquiry concerning principles of
morals or the treaties those are good
starting points for getting a sense of
like the big picture of hume's
philosophy and some of his key arguments
and assertions you know the so-called
Humes Fork you're going to get at the
end of the first inquiry that concerning
human understanding if you want that you
know reason is and can only be the slave
of the passions well that's going to
come about in in book two of the
treaties so those are good places to
start it's interesting with Hume though
because he is such a good essay writer
there are some other
entrance points that you could have so
if you like comparative philosophy and
you want to get hume's take on certain
[Music]
matters with that he has these
four essays
the Epicurean the stoic the platonist
and the skeptic that give you his point
of view he's kind of loosely connecting
these things on those four different
types or schools or temperaments in
philosophy and I think that could be
quite interesting
Hume also has quite a few
critical uh aesthetic essays that are
worth checking out and I would say the
two most important the ones that get
referenced uh quite frequently are on
the standard of taste and on tragedy you
shouldn't avoid either of those and you
can find those in these essays you know
moral political and literary
but I would also say that you might want
to
depending on what your in interest is
you might want to
early on after you've read the you know
first inquiry
approach The Works in which he's talking
about religious topics as such and some
of these are published posthumously in
part because of the milieu in which he's
in he's already you know
been turned down for a University post
because he's viewed as possibly being an
atheist would she very well very well
may have been
so you know the dialogues concerning
natural religion I've sometimes used
that as an introduction to hume's
thought in an introductory philosophy
class for people who don't have any
background in in him
um you know he's got some others the
natural history of religion very well
worth checking out of superstition and
enthusiasm he's got an essay on suicide
and a future state so those are all
important I would say starting points as
well I do want to talk about some of
these other books that I have piled up
that might be helpful for for you to
hear about so we've talked about hume's
own works right
and then I do want to mention one other
thing
um so we've got this hume's ethical
writings volume that you'll find in some
some libraries and it's edited and
introduced by Aleister McIntyre major uh
moral philosopher of the 20th and 21st
century and he's got a good editor's
introduction where he says an
introduction should introduce it should
not be an attempt as a substitute for
the book at which it's introducing I'm
not going to try here to summarize
adequately the arguments which Hume uses
in the parts of his writings which
follow I shall try rather to relate
those arguments in a simple way to the
general body of his work and to his life
and so that that's what he's doing he's
he's connecting the dots for you in the
introduction and I do want to point out
that I mean Hume is somebody that
McIntyre engages with a lot and you will
find a good discussion of him in this
short history of ethics
which is uh again from the
1960s he's got a chapter the British
18th century argument which is concerned
in large part with with Hume I'll
mention two other histories of
philosophy these two by the way are
contemporaries with each other and
before
McIntyre so uh Bertrand Russell actually
has an entire chapter devoted to Hume
I'm not a big fan of of Russell's
history of philosophy I think it has
many flaws and you know it's interesting
to read Russell's a great writer but
you're getting more Russell sometimes in
his takes than you are the actual
philosophers and uh you know he actually
I mean the section is not bad I would
say that this might give this line might
give you some idea hume's philosophy
whether true or false represents the
bankruptcy of 18th century
reasonableness right he starts out like
Locke with the intention of being
sensible and empirical taking nothing on
trust but seeking whatever instruction
is to be obtained for from experience
and observation but having a better
intellect thin locks a greater acuteness
and Analysis and a smaller capacity for
accepting comfortable inconsistencies he
arrives at the disastrous conclusion
that from experience and observation
nothing is to be learned there is no
such thing as a rational belief now that
seems a bit excessive but you know it's
it's um isn't it got an interesting take
if you want something that's a little
bit more
sedate Friedrich cobbleston's history of
philosophy the volume that is the
British philosophers from Hobbes to Hume
actually has a number of chapters going
through hume's work
um four and then a chapter entitled for
and against him talking about the
criticism and reinterpretation of Hume
and here we're talking about you know
over 100 pages of summary and Analysis
and also excerpts from his his work so
Cobblestone could be quite helpful for
you not only with Hume but in in general
I mean as a side note cobblestone was
the person who we often used in graduate
school to like you know get get boned up
on on people
um I'll also mention
some you know interpretive stuff and
actually let me begin just by bringing
up a number of let's call them essay uh
books so we've got Vera Chappelle uh did
a um um he added it a volume years back
in the 60s uh of of some pretty great
classic essays on
um David hume's work so that's worth
checking out it's just called Hume
there's obviously companions like the a
companion to Hume which is edited
um by uh Elizabeth Radcliffe published
by Blackwell again we've got 28
different essays here this is a bit more
contemporary you know we're talking 2008
so that's a good one Cambridge published
a companion to Hume uh which is that
one's got
15 different
um
assays in It Again by Major Hume
Scholars and then you know uh this is an
interesting one reading Hume on human
understanding uh this is from Oxford and
um it's it's got uh 14 different essays
uh discussing Hume it's also you know a
bit more contemporary as well so you
know well worth checking out and then
there's some a few others that I wanted
to bring up
so Norman Kemp Smith who's I think a lot
of people know more because of the con
stuff he's got a whole book here which
is about you know the philosophy of
David Hume a critical study of its
Origins and Central doctrines now you
know Kemp Smith is a philosopher writing
four other philosophers to to help him
out understanding but this is very very
comprehensive I I really enjoyed reading
it
um there's also you know AJ air wrote a
book in this past Masters uh thing on
him talking about life and character
aims and methods bodies and self-cause
and effect morals political and politics
and religion now with air you're
probably getting less Hume and more airs
tank and that is also the situation with
this Book by Jill de Luz who thought
Hume was somebody well worth studying
empiricism and subjectivity and essay on
hume's theory of human nature
I really enjoy reading to lose but
you're again with the lose you're
getting more to lose than you are the
original topic and there's two other
works I think could be useful for you at
some point or another if you like
intellectual biographies and what are
intellectual biographies they're
biographies that stress the development
of a thinker's ideas over time and what
the context is and who they're engaging
with this uh book by James Harris Hume
an intellectual biography
published 2015 I would say this is this
is probably the go-to for you and then I
want to Signal one other book that came
out recently the great guide by Julian
bagini it's it's subtitled what David
Hume can teach us about being human and
living well well so this is kind of a
biography but it's really quite
interesting because what bikini is
interested in is
um not the traditional thing let's Place
The Thinker within their their context
great stuff he wants to derive the
lessons available for us from not just
hume's writing but also his life and he
frames these in terms of human maxims
and aphorisms which you have as an
appendix in the back of the book
this is really quite quite interesting
and you know beginning is a great writer
I think you can learn a lot from that so
where to get started I think we've
talked about that quite enough at this
point
it can be quite helpful as you're
approaching an author that you're going
to study on your own granted with plenty
of help from various resources on the
internet and I mentioned these secondary
works that can be quite useful to
understand the projects and the motives
and the context of a person's writing
now Hume is part of what we call the
Enlightenment and we use that to talk
about like the 18th century and Western
Europe in general but one thing that we
really really really have to keep in
mind is The Enlightenment isn't just one
thing happening everywhere you know the
journal we could say well there's
different words for it French you know
siecta Lumiere the Germans the ALF
clerong but what we should understand is
things are happening differently in
Germany
in France in Great Britain which also
includes Scotland in America and a few
other places as well and we often talk
about the Scottish Enlightenment and you
might say that the Scotland at least the
part of it like Edinburgh that David
Hume is living in I mean he's in Paris
for a while as well
that is one of the most enlightened of
the Enlightenment places it's really
going like gangbusters and so he is a
vital part of this but he's also being
shaped by it and there's
interconnections between the continent
and and Great Britain and particularly
Scotland so you know Hume is somebody
who uh knows what's going on in
different places he's actually you know
been on the continent that's important
to know as far as the context goes
another thing that I think is really
important to understand
is that Hume is writing in a context and
a time and situation in which there are
there's a lot of upheaval and conflict
about religion you know there's this
kind of secularizing force that's
happening at the same time religious
people are pushing back I mentioned
earlier that Hume was essentially denied
a University post because of concerns
about his Orthodoxy right and Hume
himself is quite interested in religion
as a phenomenon and is something that
can get in the way of rationality and
the ongoing development of Science and
culture so you're going to see him uh as
you know a sort of a genteel opponent of
religion he's not like Thomas Paine you
know writing the Age of Reason and you
know sort of a fire brand and advocating
deism so that atheism won't bring
everything down instead Hume is taking a
different sort of approach one that I
will mention he is borrowing in part
from Cicero if you want to understand
um what Hume is doing in his dialogues
concerning natural religion it really
helps to have read
Cicero's work on the nature of the Gods
where he has again three different
people
discussing can we prove that gods exist
what are their nature and one of them is
actually going to be a skeptic who's
also a priest right so there's there's
some really interesting strategies that
are being borrowed from that and that's
because of the milieu that Hume is in he
can't he feels that he can't publish all
of his thoughts on religion because it
would get him in in some some trouble
um
I think that it's also important to
realize that
in hume's time
one way of doing philosophy that you see
you know Jean-Jacques Rousseau is
contemporary and for a while his friend
um and you know Hume is a great
benefactor of him you see Locke doing
this you see Renee Descartes doing this
is the sort of appeal to personal
experience observation and reflection
the philosopher is saying I look Within
Myself and I find this or don't find
this I find things are connected in this
way and this could actually be a little
bit off-putting to a uh reader of the
president who's like well I'm not
fighting that who the hell are you well
this is part of the
the way in which philosophy is often
being done in that time you know Hume is
also writing at a time where there is
it's not so simple as well there's
continental rationalism and British
empiricism because there's a lot of
mixing back and forth but these are two
really big overarching concerns Hume is
writing about things that maybe we don't
buy into these days like they're being
innate ideas ideas that we're born with
then again there's some people who do
believe in that stuff even today right
um so Hume is definitely taking the
empiricist side but Hume is also a
skeptic and he's not a
um as he calls it a uh extreme or
pyronian skeptic he's more of a
mitigated skeptic who says there's a lot
of stuff that we actually can't prove
100 we can only go by probabilities and
by the way cause and effect ah it's kind
of shaky when we look at it you know
there's a lot of things that we take for
granted that maybe aren't a hundred
percent or even 50 or maybe we can't
even put a number on them right that is
really Central to his motivation but
Hume is not the sort of skeptic that
wants to knock arguments down just to
knock them down he's not a spoiler he's
not a Troll he's not that kind of jerk
he genuinely wants to know he genuinely
is motivated by wanting to understand as
much as he can about human beings and
how we work that's why he actually
writes eight treaties of human nature
he's committed to the ideas that he's
setting out here about the passions or
about how the understanding works and
the ideas that we have how they're
Associated or his rather conservative
moral philosophy those are things that
he is genuinely
interested in and is trying to pursue as
best he can in a way that's rational in
a way that's based on evidence in a way
that takes us as far as we can go and
then says all right after this
we can't really know things we have to
be a little bit more careful about we
commit what we commit ourselves to and
that includes a lot of things about
social reform but it also includes a lot
of things about religious beliefs or
about metaphysics in general so that's
stuff that might be helpful for
understanding The Wider context and the
deeper motivations of Hume
I do have a bit of advice for you
derived from the format of hume's works
so a lot of what he's writing are essays
right we have somewhat systematic works
like you know the Treatise on human
nature we have dialogues at times
in the dialogues no one single person
represents hume's point of view he's
having us the reader enter in and
there's a larger strategy that that's
going on in the treaties Hume is
speaking for himself in all of these
essays he's tackling different projects
and problems and issues and sometimes
telling you what he thinks sometimes
speculating sometimes attacking other
people's stuff so you've got to pay
attention to the genre of the work that
Hume is writing in and don't have the
same expectations for each of them you
can't apply the same you know basic
assumptions about the treaties as you
can to an essay like on the standard of
of taste
um
you also don't want to be too worried
about perfect consistency because
frankly
that doesn't actually exist for Hume
if you take everything that he's saying
very literally and apply it to his own
works it doesn't all add up but that
doesn't mean that it's thereby you know
annulled or no good or anything like
that it just means that you can only
push things so far I mean he does
actually make claims in the inquiry
concerning human understanding about
human nature that given all the things
he said about causality and observation
he probably doesn't have any right to
make but you got to like go with it and
see what he's actually trying to say and
then I always say first you understand
then you criticize so generating an
understanding of what he's saying is is
very important entering into kind of a
dialogue with the work and I think you
should as you're trying to read Hume
after you get past the you know
vocabulary which may be a little tricky
for you for reasons we've already talked
about think of it as you dialoguing with
this this really interesting great
thinker who's also you know not perfect
and doesn't claim to be so re-reading
you know going back over the passages
reflecting on it trying to apply it to
your own life and situation having a
conversation or entering into the
conversation that Hume himself is having
with the reader you and me that can be
quite helpful I also think that he's
going to make a lot of hyperbolic
statements you know we talked about
hume's fork and can sign those books to
the Flames he doesn't really mean that
um and you know reason is and can only
be the slave of the passions does he
really mean that no you could read his
work and find out that that's not the
case and I mean if it was he wouldn't
write the treaties in the first place so
when you encounter these big hyperbolic
statements realize that those are those
are rhetoric those are he you being
somebody who comes up with a great line
and realizes that this can be used to
hook the reader it's almost like he's
created a bunch of memes you know more
than two centuries before memes are
identified as such and then morph into
what we now call internet memes
um so you know that could be helpful as
you're you're reading them the other
thing is you know realize that
this is the last part these works are
written for a literate audience who will
take the time to read them don't try to
speed run through these things you're
not going to get anything out of doing
that with Hume any more than you would
with Hegel or Nietzsche or or any other
great author these are designed to be
lingered over and and thought through
okay so there's also what we can call
problems and issues that you as a
beginner don't necessarily need to worry
about like did Hume you know
fully treat the problem of induction uh
figure out what the hell Hume is
actually saying first before worrying
about that sort of of matter
um you know he's going to say a lot of
things about a lot of things and
sometimes Stakeout would appear to be
pretty extreme positions
um Hume by his very nature is not I mean
he is radical in certain uh respects but
he's not that radical you know he can
undermine causality cause and effect and
say yeah you know we don't really
understand what's going on there but
then he comes up with his own theory
about how that works that's based on
habit and custom and actually a certain
kind of instinct even we can talk about
um and then he can be perfectly fine to
go and play some pool as he calls it you
know walk into his Billiards room and
not worry about these metaphysical
concerns or doubts so keep that in mind
as you're you're reading him I mean
there's some really cool implications to
what Hume is saying but he is not
himself given to following out that
hyperbole that he sometimes uses so you
know when it's not as if we read human
now there's no certainty or probability
about anything another good example I
don't find any sensation or you know
little nodule that is myself that
doesn't mean that we don't have selves
you know when Hume is concerned with big
picture issues
he's not taking a stand that is as
radical or unreasonable as we we might
believe right Hume obviously believed
that he's an author that there's at
least some bits that are kind of
permanent he's just saying there's no
one single thing we can call ourself and
now that leads to another interesting
topic that I think you don't have to
worry about
is hume's concern about the self the
same thing as buddhism's doctrine of
anatman no self I mean for
deal with the fact that there's many
different ways of interpreting that
within Buddhism because it's not like
there's one big thing out there called
Buddhism there's a whole bunch of
different schools put that aside
did Hume get this from the Buddhists we
don't know people are making arguments
one way or the other we've not arrived
at any sort of scholarly consensus about
that yes or no and in a way it doesn't
really matter that much where he got the
ideas from he he's he's worked out the
ideas and he's providing them to you
these are not things that a beginner has
to be particularly concerned about maybe
later on down the line if you're really
really into him those will be concerns
for you one other thing that I think
that maybe you don't need to worry too
much about politically Hume was quite
conservative he was what they call a
Tory back then
and you know when you read through his
Works you're going to see that he
doesn't want an awful lot of change he
actually winds up being a quite
important author in terms of his uh
ethics and political philosophy for at
least thoughtful conservativism I mean
he would take a look at what what's
called conservativism today and probably
bend over and puke uh because it's it's
not conservative hasn't even like
conserved what conservativism is but
that don't worry about that either so
much so you know you can you can be
wherever you want in the political
Spectrum or spectrums and you can read
Hume and get something out of it you
don't have to worry about what his
politics were or you know his stance on
the American Revolution that's kind of
uh extraneous to the epistemology and
the metaphysics and even a lot of the
moral philosophy so you don't need to
worry too much about those matters
so just a few words to end I think you
can tell that David Hume is somebody who
although I don't agree with him on a lot
of things I I think he's a really
important and interesting philosopher
somebody who's actually fun to read and
think along with I mentioned you know
being like a conversation partner with
him and I think that his Works once you
understand them really do lend
themselves to that and I hope that these
uh bits of advice that I've given you
prove helpful for those of you who want
to study David Hume or perhaps have
already begun studying David hume's
works and thought he's definitely not
somebody who you want to skip in the
history of philosophy and you'll
probably derive a lot of benefit from
engaging with his works and thought even
if you do find yourself at odds with or
critical of him on a lot of points I
mean think about just for an example of
that that Hume talks about uh or Khan
talks about Hume as Awakening him from
this dogmatic Slumber and he you know
gets another first-rate philosopher
engaged in stuff that we will consider
to be his major work and so I think
David Hume can do things sort of like
that for for you but you might also be
attracted to his thought you won't know
until you get on the David Hume train
and we've mentioned there's a lot of
different ways that you can go with it
they're all fine just keep on studying
keep on reading and you know we'll be
doing many more of these self-directed
study advice videos about all sorts of
other philosophers you might find it
useful to go back to some of the ones
that I've already developed so there you
go that's all that I have to say happy
reading ahead